let's say that you want to count the
days since your last birthday because
you just want to know how long it's been
and so one day after your birthday you
put a mark on a wall then the next day
you put another mark on the wall the day
after that you put another mark on the
wall so out that day you say well how
many days has it been well you could say
look there's it's been one two three
days so one way to think about it is
this this set of symbols right over here
represents the number three but then you
keep going the fourth day you put
another mark fifth day you put another
mark and you keep going like that day
after day each day you add another mark
and this is actually the earliest way
the most basic way of representing
numbers a number is represented by the
number of marks so after a bunch of days
you get here and you're like oh well how
many days has it been well you just
recount everything you say 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 days
say well you know this number
representation it took me a little bit
of time to realize that this is 17 but
it seems to be working so you just keep
going
day after day after day after day you
just
keep marking off the days on your wall
just essentially counting the days since
your last birthday
but at some point you realize every time
you want to know how many days it's been
to count it is a little bit painful and
not only that this is taking up a lot of
space on your wall you wish that there
was an easier way to represent whatever
number this is so first of all let's
just think about what number this
actually is
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18
19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31
32 33 34 35 36 37
so you wish that there was a better way
to represent this number which we now
call 37 and maybe when you're first
trying you might have even called it
something called 37 you would just call
it this this number this number of days
since my birthday
i said well look what if there's an easy
way to group the numbers you know i have
10 fingers on my hands what if i were to
group them into tens and then i would
say how many groups of 10 i have and
then how many ones do i have left over
maybe that would be an easier way to
represent to represent this quantity
here and so let's do that so 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10.
so that's a group of 10
right over there
and then you have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. so this is another
group of 10
right over here
and then let's see we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10. so that is another group of 10
right over there
and then finally you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7.
so you don't get a whole group of 10 so
you don't circle them so just by doing
this very simple thing now all of a
sudden it's much easier to realize how
many days have passed you don't have to
count everything you just have to say
okay one group of ten two groups of ten
three groups of ten or you could say one
two three tens
and so that's essentially 30 and then i
have another one two three four five six
seven and so you say oh i have 30 and
then seven if you if you knew to use
those words which we now use
and this is essentially what our number
system does using the 10 digits we know
of the 10 digits we know of are 0 1 2 3
4 5 6
7
8 9. and what our number system allows
us to do is using only these 10 digits
we can essentially represent any number
we want in a very quick way a very easy
way for our brains to understand it
so here if we want to represent three
tens
we would have put a three in what we
would call the tens place
we would put a three
in the tens place and then we would put
the ones one two three four five six
seven we'd put the 7
in the ones place and so how do you know
which place is which
well the first place starting from the
right the first place is the ones place
and then you go one space to the left of
it you get to the tens place and as
we'll see you go one more space you go
to the hundreds place but we'll cover
that in a future video
so this essentially tells us the exact
same thing
this tells us the exact same thing as
this does right over here
this tells us three tens one two three
three tens three groups of ten
and then another seven ones so we could
rewrite this
this is equal to
this is equal to
three
tens
three tens
plus
plus
seven ones
or another way to think about it what
are three tens well if we use the same
number system to represent three tens
you would write that down as 30 and then
seven ones once again if you use our
same number system you would represent
that
as seven so these are all different ways
of representing 37 and hopefully this
allows you to appreciate how neat our
number system is well even a number like
37 as soon as you just write scratches
on the wall
it becomes pretty hard to read and you
can imagine when you get to much much
larger numbers like
1052 to have to count that many marks
every time but our number system gives
us a way of dealing with it